on n'est pas dans le pays pour on va
parler des riches les gens qui sont
riches pourquoi sont-ils utiles dans ce
pays ce qu'il faut leur cracher dessus à
quel moment on est riche à quel salaire
on est riche qu'est-ce qu'on appelle un
riche combien de milliards en France
est-ce que la France est un pays riche
tout ça avec Fabrice dalmeda qui est
avec nous feuille blanche
bonsoir
bienvenue déjà tu as une bonne tête de
capitaliste
comme ça tu sais quand tu reçois un
communiste il a une écharpe une pipe
alors chers Fabrice bravo pour le
bouquin que j'ai lu merci parce qu'en
fait il est passionnant parce qu'il y a
de la sociologie sur sur la France sur
l'histoire parce que la France décède un
pays riche que combien de milliardaire
en France en France on en a un peu plus
d'une quarantaine je crois 43 c'est mon
souvenir exact on en a et ce qui est
assez surprenant parce qu'on a une
population beaucoup plus grande à peu
près autant que la Suède on en a moitié
moins que la Russie et on en a à peu
près
20 à 25 fois moins que la Chine et 20
fois moins que les États-Unis ce qui
veut baiser effectivement
beaucoup plus jeunes dans quelques
années le français vous l'apprendrez
comme le latin ça sera une langue morte
et vous parlerez chinois et espagnol
maintenant parce qu'on va relever le
défi
la Grèce antique avait déjà dit ça et
maintenant vous allez les visiter avec
un plus grand milliardaire du monde et
français en ce moment en profiter
Bernard faut en profiter mais en Europe
parce qu'on est payé où il y a plus de
milliardaires non en Europe c'est
l'Allemagne de milliardaire ensuite on
doit avoir la grande
si on compte par habitant c'est la
Suisse mais je pense que l'Angleterre en
a en a plus par habitant aussi il faut
pas sous-estimer les j'ai parlé de la
Suède Suède Danemark
ce qui m'étonnent parlons un peu de
politique de ce que vous me dites c'est
que
Suède Angleterre souvent souvent des
pays en fait qui sont très très riches
qui ont beaucoup de milliardaires et qui
sont sortis de l'Europe très souvent
oui mais quand même le la fortune solide
c'est quand même l'Allemagne
il y a de quoi faire alors vous dites ça
va vous passionné vous écrivez 1% des
plus riches possèdent en France 50% des
richesses
c'est incroyable ouais mais j'allais
dire c'est un petit peu dans le dans le
mood si on compare à l'é mondial on
n'est pas très loin on a à peu près des
chiffres équivalents ça doit être à 40
45%. et j'ai lu sur j'ai renseigné parce
que votre film m'a passionné par exemple
quand on gagne 2200 euros par mois à peu
près on fait partie des 30 % des
Français et 1% des Français gagnent 9000
€ net par mois ça veut dire que si vous
gagnez à partir de 9000 euros par mois
vous êtes vous faites partie des 1 % et
souvent on a on n'a pas ces chiffons là
mais en fait être riche c'est pas
seulement des revenus c'est en général
un capital un patrimoine un patrimoine
et donc si on commence à regarder le
patrimoine là ça accro un petit peu le
nombre de personnes qui sont qui sont
riches en France et les gens qui sont
riches en France est-ce que pardon on
est débile et on n'arrive pas à l'être
où est-ce qu'en fait tous viennent de
grandes grandes grandes familles dont
ils héritent et
qu'il récupère alors il y a richer riche
il y a des petits riches quelqu'un comme
vous dites qui gagne 9000 euros par mois
s'il a pas de patrimoine c'est un petit
riche en réalité et après il y a les
vrais riches dont
c'est un petit peu ça ils sont ils sont
ceux sur lesquels on ce dont on pense
qu'ils sont capables d'investir et de le
faire intelligemment et bien et pourquoi
vous avez voulu comme ça écrire un
bouquin sur les milliardaires d'abord
pourquoi ils ont parlé moi historien
donc au départ j'ai commencé à
travailler sur un autre régime qui était
l'Allemagne nazi et j'avais regardé les
relations entre l'argent et le pouvoir
et je me suis dit mais comment ça se
passe ailleurs et c'est comme ça qui est
né l'idée de de faire une histoire plus
générale
des rapports entre l'argent et le
pouvoir et c'est un peu ça et c'est une
questionne aussi après je sais que je
mais pardon mais la richesse c'est
économiste
aux États-Unis on sait très bien que la
politique n'a aucun pouvoir les riches
longs on le voit avec le lobby des armes
par exemple il y avait des aînés qu'on
veut l'enlever ils disent non c'est tout
et sinon tu n'es pas réélu et même les
gens risquent payent les campagnes
est-ce qu'en France ce sont les
milliardaires où ce sont les hommes
politiques qui tiennent les reines du
pays alors il y a ça dépend des mots
comme dirait l'autre ça dépend des
moments il y a des moments dans notre
histoire ont effectivement le pouvoir
politique est très très puissant en
général quand on regarde les guerres
mondiales à la Première Guerre mondiale
le pouvoir politique a imposé beaucoup
de choses aux riches et leur imposé de
prendre des fonds d'investissement enfin
des obligations en fait des empreintes
d'État ils en ont pris beaucoup alors
que les emprunts étaient très mauvais on
leur a imposé l'impôt sur le revenu il y
avait pas l'impôt sur le revenu avant la
Première Guerre mondiale faut avoir
conscience de ça et le pire c'est que
c'est un impôt où il devait faire
eux-mêmes la déclaration et il y avait
pas de contrôle donc ceux qui
acceptaient de payer c'était et en fait
une bonne partie des riches ont accepté
de payer donc ça veut dire qu'il y avait
quand même une logique patriotique
depuis au fond la Cinquième République
on s'aperçoit que c'est quand même il y
a un certain nombre de choses qui sont
négociées qui sont discutés on peut pas
dire que c'est les riches qui ont
absolument le pouvoir donc c'est le
pouvoir politique qui mène complètement
la danse on essaye de se débrouiller et
tout c'est difficile il fait quand c'est
privé et tout ça la politique n'a pas
beaucoup de pouvoir ce qui m'intéresse
c'est que dans les années 80 vous dites
à l'instar des des top models Naomi
Campbell et tout ça les riches de ont un
égo surdimensionnés encore pire que les
stars de télé et tout ça et ça devient
des stars dans les années 80 et là c'est
le concours de tube qui a le plus gros
jet qui est le plus gros en France
effectivement c'est ce que dit la
fontaine à ce moment-là dans les années
80 on se dit c'est toute entreprise il y
a eu tchatcheur en Angleterre Ryan aux
États-Unis en France et socialiste
change de philosophie à partir de 83-84
donc c'est l'entreprise c'est c'est ce
qu'on veut mettre en avant et donc ça
pousse et ça me met en vedette des
riches on parle de tapis mais il faut se
souvenir de Jean-Luc Lagardère à
l'époque d'Alain Gomez qui était le PDG
de Thomson ça devient des figures qui
tout d'un coup sont calvaises chez
Peugeot qui passe au journal télévisé et
même les Français se disent bien tiens
pourquoi un calvaire serait pas candidat
à la présidence de la République et avec
la décomplexion qu'elle avait que moi je
me suis en début des années 80 on a ça
va arriver les émissions avec les
faiseurs de feu qui est un bouquin qui
est sorti qui s'appelait les faiseurs du
fric de Dominique Fischer
absolue de l'année toutes les années 80
et au même moment aux États-Unis et ben
il y a la financarisation il y a Anthony
blinken il y a des nouvelles manières
d'investir qui sont devenus ensuite des
films le loup de Wall Street c'est ça
raconte ses aventures là
chaque année le magazine forme parce que
ta mère elle m'a dit américain classe le
classement un peu comme les animateurs
préférés des français le classement des
plus grandes fortunes et il paraît que
celui qui passe deux ou trois il y a eu
des anecdotes de personnes que je ne
citerai pas est en Bernard Arnaud et
puis on a évidemment Pinot tout ça qui
avait perdu j'aurais pas dire de quel
c'est il est prenait un petit déjeuner
il ouvre fort et il voit qu'il passe
derrière son ennemi et il embarque tout
le petit déjeuner et il jette tout et
puis qu'une crise de nerfs il pèse 783
milliards de dollars mais il a appris
qu'il a perdu 100 millions et que du
coup il passe derrière son ennemi c'est
ouais mais vous imaginez Elon Musk qui
en quelques semaines a perdu 200
milliards 200 milliards forts pour avoir
présenté simplement parce que le cours
de l'action Tesla a baissé donc c'est un
Oui-Oui effectivement mais parce que au
fond chez ses chez ses grands fauves sur
ces grands riches il y a toujours
l'envie d'être meilleur il y a toujours
envie et puis il y a aussi un petit
frisson c'est qu'ils ont le sentiment
que aussi vite ils sont montés aussi
vite il pourrait descendre donc c'est
pour ça qu'ils vivent un petit peu dans
une angoisse et dans une pression
constante à surveiller les cours de
bourse à surveiller la moindre chose de
leur entreprise j'ai une question à vous
poser qui m'intéresse parce qu'il y
avait un économiste américain qui avait
dit si vous n'êtes pas millionnaire à 30
ans vous ne serez jamais sous-entendu
c'est quelque chose qu'on a qu'on a en
soi l'argent et je me souviens de
Bloomberg qui était le maire de New York
qui touche 100 millions d'euros de
dollars à l'époque et on lui dit
qu'est-ce que vous allez faire je pense
que nous tout le monde ici on dit une
maison dans le sud de la France une
maison à Paris une belle voiture et on
kiffe Belhadi je vais tout réinvestir
c'est-à-dire que c'est c'est une maladie
non c'est pas une maladie c'est une
passion c'est une passion et il faut il
faut avoir présent à l'esprit que le bon
riche le vrai riche est un riche
actionnaire c'est quelqu'un qui détient
une entreprise c'est pas seulement
quelqu'un qui gagne d'argent Bernard
Arnault en fait son salaire je crois que
c'est moins de 2 millions d'euros par an
mais mais c'est revenu en action c'est
revenu en accès plusieurs centaines de
millions d'euros donc ça n'a rien à voir
donc quelqu'un qui gagne comme ça
plusieurs centaines de millions d'euros
il est réinvesti immédiatement c'est
c'est comme ça que Liliane Bettencourt
en fait a été la meilleure actionnaire
de sa génération elle réinvestissait
tout et ensuite elle avait des tactiques
elle se faisait présenter tous les
produits elle était très attentive c'est
des gens au fond c'est des gens qui
bossent comme des dingues il faut
exactement se mentir la plupart du temps
nous on s'imagine le riche sur une plage
dans le Pacifique allongée en train de
boire des cocktails non c'est pas vrai
la plupart du temps le riche il est dans
un bureau en train de regarder des
chiffres en train de recevoir des gens
de chercher des opportunités
d'investissement et effectivement
pendant que nous quand on gagne de
l'argent on le dépense eux ils
réinvestissent je n'ai plus de regard de
questions donc je vais prendre par nos
Deborah et la dernière sera la mienne
vous avez une question vous parlez de
Michael Jackson aussi dans votre livre
par exemple et je me suis toujours
demandé pourquoi quand les gros
classements sortent comme ceux de Forbes
on y voit jamais des noms de célébrités
ou de gens connus que des hommes
d'affaires
tu es dans le classement
et maintenant elle a créé un empire
exactement
quand François Hollande a dit un jour à
4000 euros à combien à combien est-on
riche à 4000 € on est riche alors il
suivait la logique des organisations de
lutte contre la pauvreté les
organisations de lutte contre la
pauvreté considèrent que on est riche
quand on touche trois fois le salaire
minimum ou deux fois le salaire médian
c'est à dire environ 4000 4500 euros
aujourd'hui et les Français eux-mêmes
quand on les interroge disent qu'on est
riche à peu près quand on gagne 5000
euros par mois mais la réalité de notre
monde c'est qu'on est riche quand on est
puissant le mot riche en fait au
Moyen-Âge ça signifie être puissant et
donc les puissants par l'argent c'est
des gens qui ont des surfs des fortunes
mais beaucoup plus colossales que ça
c'est pour ça que je parle de
milliardaire c'est pour ça je parle même
de multimilliardaires des gens qui
peuvent peser sur la politique mondiale
bon ça c'est vraiment génial franchement
bravo
urbanisme par exemple qu'il soit très
riche c'est pas gênant du tout mais que
le Nice des quartiers de Paris qui sont
plus parisiens et en même temps il
colonise et il collectionne des
vignobles il a plus d'une cinquantaine
d'appellations parmi les plus grands
champagnes donc problème c'est parce que
les champagnes que je bois aussi plus
modeste comme Le Mercier ben
effectivement c'est vrai que les riches
sont les on les je gère pas font les
méprises parce qu'on est jalouse mais il
faut les garder parce que on n'a pas
trouvé pour l'instant de de
d'alternative c'est à dire que les pays
où il y a pas de riche en général sont
des pays où on vit moins bien que les
pays où il y a des pourquoi tu crois que
je colle merci beaucoup Fabrice merci
Fabrice d'avoir été avec nous c'était
passionnant c'est passionnant le bouquin
est passionnant merci beaucoup au revoir
au revoir au revoir
ça c'est des livres à lire sur la plage
ou en vacances parce que c'est génial
t'apprends des trucs incroyables et
effectivement il y a des gens qui sont
qui sont bien et quand même dans un